[Música]
la oposición chilena presentó una
acusación para destituir al presidente
sebastián piñera por la polémica venta
de un megaproyecto minero en un paraíso
fiscal revelada en los papeles de
pandora se trata de un proceso histórico
pues por segunda vez desde que asumió en
2018 piñera afronta una petición de
destitución es además el segundo
presidente chileno en ejercicio que
encara un juicio por américo el proceso
complicar a los últimos meses de su
gobierno que terminará su segundo
mandato no consecutivo en marzo del
próximo año 2022 para ello yo le quiero
dar la bienvenida a nuestro segundo
invitado del día el es félix gonzález
diputado chileno presidente del partido
ecológico verde que ha firmado estas
acusaciones en contra piñera diputado
gonzález gracias por estar aquí en
directo américa de france 24 me pregunto
qué pasará ahora cómo puede prosperar
este mecanismo que ustedes están
liderando
unos muy buenos días la verdad es que a
nosotros como cámara diputado nos
corresponde la fiscalización del
gobierno entonces es una obligación
nuestra fiscalizar lo en este caso que
además es un escándalo internacional y
la constitución actual nos permite
hacer esta acusación
cuando hay faltas a la probidad y
también cuando se pone en riesgo el
honor de la nación y estas dos cosas han
ocurrido por eso es que ayer muy
temprano presentamos la acusación
constitucional
se nombró la comisión que tiene que
investigar y luego se tiene que votar en
la cámara diputados y después en el
senado y sinceramente esta es la segunda
vez que se hace una acusación y es el
primer presidente que tiene una
acusación constitucional de este calibre
en la primera acusación fue el 2019 por
serias violaciones a los derechos
humanos en la represión del estallido
social y hay unos sectores de oposición
que terminaron salvando al presidente
piñera ahora en esta segunda acusación
ellos han comprometido sus votos para
poder aprobarla al menos en la cámara
diputados así que esperamos que prospere
porque la verdad es que ésta ha sido el
peor presidente de la historia chile
ahora félix y le quiero preguntar cuáles
son estas faltas de las que usted habla
por parte de piñera en esta oportunidad
bueno hay una zona en nuestro país que
está en la zona más desértica que es la
región de coquimbo y en la costa de la
región de coquimbo está la reserva más
grande de pingüinos de humboldt
probablemente la gente piensa que los
pingüinos están solo la antártida y no
también está en el desierto y la reserva
más grande está ahí y hay un proyecto
minero y portuario que se llama dominga
que era de propiedad de la familia el
presidente piñera era propiedad de él y
se vende el 2010 en islas vírgenes
británicas a su mejor amigo que el señor
del ano y hay una cláusula en ese
contrato y esa es la información nueva
que apareció hace poco con los pandora
papers
qué dice que es que el tercer pago
alrededor de 10 millones de dólares está
supeditado a que no se proteja la zona
no se declara reserva marina protegida y
es algo que este presidente ha cumplido
porque ha no ha avanzado en nada en la
protección del lugar y acelerado por el
contrario los permisos para el proyecto
que era de su propiedad y que ahora de
propiedad su mejor amigo entonces cuando
se ponen una cláusula compromisos que
tienen que ver con el cargo de este
periodo no del 2010 de este periodo eso
claramente es un cohecho es tráfico de
influencia es una falta la propiedad
agradable de parte presidente de la
república por eso merece ser destituido
diputado que dice al gobierno cómo se
defiende el presidente piñera ante estas
acusaciones ustedes como a que se
enfrentarán digamos con la defensa al
presidente piñera bueno es una defensa
de alguien que ya ha sido pillado
digamos sorprendido porque lo que dice
es que era algo que ya conocido lo que
es totalmente falso a ustedes mismos a
través de los medios internacionales por
algo de un escándalo es una información
nueva el que haya se haya vendido en
islas en islas vírgenes británicas al
otro que dice que también es inverosímil
es que él no sabía nada porque él este
contrato lo hicieron sus hijos entonces
la verdad es que nosotros tenemos un
dicho con chile que decimos somos tontos
hasta las 12 el día después de eso ya no
porque es imposible que sus hijos y su
mejor amigo con una transacción de 138
millones de dólares no le digan en una
reunión en un cumpleaños en una comida
durante todos estos años que hicieron
esa venta supeditada a que no se proteja
la zona de la higuera en la comunidad
minera donde ésta estaría emplazado este
proyecto portuario domingo que en chile
es totalmente rechazado mayoritariamente
los chilenos y chilenas no queremos ser
proyecto porque estudio la naturaleza
eso le quería preguntar cómo hace el
sentir de los chilenos en torno a este
escándalo de pandora papers que salpica
como lo estábamos hablando al presidente
al presidente piñera además con esta
zona natural y por todo lo que estamos
viendo en nuestro planeta con todos los
cambios y usted además muy competente
siendo el presidente del partido
ecológico verde chileno
dentro del partido somos
mayoritariamente activistas y desde
siempre desde hace muchos años entonces
sabemos cuando hay un gobierno que está
comprometido con una empresa y en este
caso era muy evidente que el gobierno
estaba del lado de en el caso el señor
de la noaa de más amigos el presidente
pero con esto de que hay un una cláusula
que tiene asociado un pago de 10
millones de dólares para que no se
proteja la zona nos queda en evidencia
que
ha sobrepasado todos los límites ahora
es un presidente nosotros lo conocemos
bien acá no sé qué tanto lo conocen en
otros países pero es un presidente que
tiene muchos escándalos parecidos fue
declarado reo en su momento por un
desfalco en el banco de talca
hubo un uso de información privilegiada
cuando era diputado tiene mucho
escándalo y eso está también en la
acusación está en el escrito porque es
un presidente que tiene un prontuario de
faltar a la verdad
y en ese contexto también a nosotros nos
parece a los que presentábamos empujamos
la acusación constitucional la primera
el 2019 por violación al derecho humano
que no puede terminar su periodo un
presidente que ha cruzado todos los
límites para nosotros debido ha sido
actitud del 2019 lamentamos que haya
habido parlamentario incluso oposición
que nos salvaron que consideraron que no
era grave lo que lo que ocurrió hubo
cientos de jóvenes que perdieron sus
ojos fue muy brutal y nos recuerda al
caso al capone no cae por delitos de
sangre pero termina cayendo por delitos
económicos si tiene que ser así bueno
que sea así pero es un presidente que ha
generado mucho dolor en la ciudadanía
feliz 30 segunditos en materia de
conservación del medio ambiente como
esta chile en este momento
como todo el planeta creo hay una crisis
climática que nosotros nos está
afectando dramáticamente las sequías e
incendios los inviernos entre los
veranos no nos tiene con una crisis
hídrica muy severa una crisis
alimentaria también en el término al
legislativo hemos avanzado en eliminar
los plásticos algunos plásticos
hemos avanzado también hay un proyecto
que es nuestro que es para cerrar las
termoeléctricas a carbón que ya fue
aprobado en la cámara pero duerme en el
senado en el senado suele ser el colador
de la mantención del statu quo pero
estamos muy esperanzados porque tenemos
además un proceso constituyente en chile
derivado del exterior social y ahí
esperamos que elimine el senado y
también que se enfrente a la crisis
climática desde ahí también por félix y
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
que tenga usted un feliz el resto día en
chile